[Música]
hola buenas tardes yo estoy aquí para
platicarles un poquito de lo que es
vivir con una discapacidad o horas antes
del auge de youtube en la que se llama
hipoxia perinatal que es una falta de
oxígeno lo que ocasionó un daño cerebral
en el área motriz y de lenguaje donde
las áreas de mi cerebro están
perfectamente o por lo menos eso creo yo
entonces yo primera gente
y tuve la fortuna de contar en esa días
con unos padres maravillosos que
entendieron mi discapacidad como un reto
de vida y no como un problema y es aquí
donde radica la gran diferencia cuando
unos padres de un niño que nace con un
escapar real la entienden cómo no
entender mis padres se crean bases
sólidas sobre las cuales vas a comenzar
a edificar su vida
todos los seres humanos tenemos
obstáculos en esta vida pero para una
persona con discapacidad esos cálculos
se multiplican 23 en a veces no se
cuenta entonces tienes que tener
tenacidad y más tenacidad y su
importancia para lograr los objetivos
donde muy pequeña yo estuve en terapias
físicas y en terapias de lenguaje pero
yasser a pie que mejor me sirvieron y me
siguen sirviendo y me van a dar ni de
atender aquella mujer a todas las
terapias que yo nombro las presas
mágicas de una nueva si es porque hay un
bien
por ejemplo yo comencé a caminar a los 3
años de aquí entonces dada 23 pasas y
punto no hay caía desde voltear a ver a
mi mamá pidiéndole ayuda y ahí salí a la
plaza mágica levántate por lo tanto él
no me quedaba por werner más que buscar
en dónde apoyarme donde me a levantar y
dar otros 45 pasos y volver a caer
cada vez eran más los pasos que daban y
menos las caídas que tenía toda esta
apertura ya bajaron de rodillas desde ya
para tratar
pues os traigo pantalones
bueno otras de las brasas mágicas y yo
recuerdo mucho fue al momento de que yo
le dije a mi mamá sabes que yo quiero
aprender a montar en bicicleta igual que
todas mis amigas ok
área de montaña bicicleta de tierra
entonces no voy a mentirte al principio
pues muy difícil
para mantener el equilibrio y de nuevo
terminaba en sueldo
ahora la caída era un poco más drástica
porque ya lo hice que allá arriba en mí
entonces mí no me había energía aún te
quedan ganas de aprender a montar en
bicicleta si ambas después levanta te
sacudes móntate y vuelve a intentar
finalmente domine la bicicleta
el tiempo pasa
y llega la época indie carmen tienen que
entrar a la escuela ya buenas que yo a
los tres años que en el día que empecé a
caminar ya sabía
así que acaba de unas cosas por otros
pero él es en la escuela fue muy difícil
al principio los voy a ubicar a la niña
de vientos 80 el tema de la discapacidad
era casi como un tabú
entonces ella se cuida regulares no me
quería vos por mi discapacidad
hasta que finalmente realidad te va
poniendo el camino correcto y hay
personas ideales y conseguimos una
escuela en donde las maestras se unieron
al esfuerzo de nosotras y finalmente fue
estabilizar mi vida escolar
primaria secundaria bachiller
profesional siempre fui una alumna que
se sacaban los primeros lugares
académica
pero
si ustedes me preguntan a qué época
escolar me quisiera regresar sin
pensarlo dos veces y odio a mi época de
la sencillez porque porque fueron los
tres años maravillosos en bachiller que
tuve fue por primera vez tenía un grupo
de amigas
y es fundamental para todos los seres
humanos tener un grupo
para poder de sentir aceptados incluidos
y así poder desarrollar en todo su
potencial
aparte que tenía mi grupo de amigas
yo era salir a la que ya tenía que dar
la cara por todas
finalmente
llegó el tiempo de graduarme
de comparar un público vital
ahí es en donde me di cuenta de la
realidad que vivimos en el país
como todo recién egresado y con todas
las ganas de buscar trabajo para poner
en práctica mis conocimientos empezarán
a mi propio dinero y te topas con una
pared simplemente no te dan trabajo
motivos que tienes una discapacidad
pérez ortiz empiezas a trabajar por un
rumbo independientemente
te vienen soltura las una factura tienes
que pagar impuestos y ahí es muy capaz y
está
auschwitz
felicidades porque se le ocurre a carmen
para hacer un tren de un escenario a
practicar su historia de vida porque yo
quiero sensibilizar a la sociedad para
que los discapacitados que vienen detrás
de mí no tengan que la talla lo que yo
he batallado al contrario que ellos
sigan la lucha contra la discriminación
y a favor de la inclusión en juntos en
nombre yo me usted
para mí es una gran alegría cada vez que
una empresa me abre la puerta para ellos
puedan dar pláticas
bueno en cada plática que yo doy
les digo a la gente que una persona con
discapacidad no es una persona un
retraso mental son dos cosas que se
confunden y hay dos palabras muy
importantes
y hay que recalcar en esta práctica esta
pasión e inclusión la aceptación es que
ya tramitan en una empresa y tengan un
escritorio y te pongas a trabajar
pero la inclusión es que te hagan parte
del grupo y amoral cuando se va el jefe
de ti por alguna plática que también ve
a ti con ella eso hoy la aceptación
hasta cierto punto se puede decir de
esas proponen ya que hay leyes que ya
están defendiendo los derechos debe
hacer solo discapacidad y aparte te dan
incentivos fiscales pero en la inclusión
para la inclusión no hay ninguna ley
la única bueno si hay un y en la que
tenemos cada quien aquí adentro
la ley de ella con tiempo la manda y la
única que no se puede ni cambiar ni de
hogar
entonces que el público yo les pido que
si algún día tienen la oportunidad o
está en sus manos dar trabajo a una
persona finge ser discapacitada pero
capacitada para el trabajo que se le
asignó tienen esa oportunidad porque no
solamente se van a dar
sino que también ustedes se van a dar la
oportunidad de convivir con unas
personas
ya por último en tiempo de juego
alcorta
y es quiero compartir la frase que test
me pidió para este evento el cual reza
así la discapacidad no es una elección
pero la inclusión es una decisión y esa
decisión está en cada uno de nosotros
gracias pueden estarlo
[Aplausos]
[Música]